mosaic is a game where you can't find
anything to eat in the fridge you can't
afford to pay your bills and there's
nothing good on TV it's also a game
where you need to decide whether to
flush the talking goldfish that
magically appeared in your sink I'll
bring it to work with you that's the
main takeaway I came away with after the
40 odd minute demo I played a head of
mosaics yet to be determined release
date the vibe of krill bytes latest
adventure is that of your absolute worst
day turned up to 11 the environment is
cold and empty the characters are
expressionless your job is crappy and
your company regularly sends you stats
on how badly you're performing compared
to your colleagues no one will make eye
contact with you in the elevator and
there's nothing about you or your life
that appears to set you apart from
anybody else in your corporate dystopia
you begin the game underwater surfacing
from a dreamlike world into your sterile
drab apartment you have three texts on
your phone when you wake up your loving
mum asking if you're coming home for
your dad's birthday a friend cutting you
off because of your lack of effort in
the friendship and a stupid mobile game
that serves as a perfect microcosm for
the rest of your life infinitely
repeating a dull and seemingly pointless
task in order to do more of said tasks
from the real reward the act of playing
the game entitled blip blop is a
relatable parallel for your character an
average commuter unsatisfied with this
job which entails crossing off gibberish
milestones through repetitive tasks in
order to feed some ominous and ambiguous
larger scheme there's a palpable sense
of loneliness isolation and despondency
but it's this tone that makes you
curious enough to act out since to stick
to the status quo would be quite frankly
depressing there's no other incentive to
do so and as with the real world it's
easy to turn right when you hit the
sidewalk and follow the expressionless
parade of workers down the big grey
Street
pass the big grey cars to your big grey
building to do your stunningly dull grey
work tasks but what if you went left
what if instead of walking toward the
elevator when leaving your apartment you
walk toward the window to take a look
outside it's in these entirely optional
moments that mosaic shines literally
shines
peering out the window causes a
saturated rainbow to weave above your
head and clicking on it when it appears
makes all sorts of things happen from
breaking the window and being and
developed by an imagined sunset to
saving a cat from a tree and having it
purr with gratitude in your arms these
moments are easy enough to miss but
finding one makes you yearn for more as
it's the singular escape from your
otherwise bleak reality perhaps girl
bite is sending a larger message here or
perhaps the heights of luminosity are
being used to contrast just how dark the
underbelly of mosaics dystopia gets
there are glimpses of this darkness
through cryptic static encoded messages
that invade your screen but unraveling
the mysteries of what why and how will
presumably only become clearer when the
full game arrives my experienced sofa
insinuate that the path to your everyday
grind is paved with nothing out of the
ordinary but the road less traveled the
possibilities of what could be waiting
in that direction of something else
entirely and mosaic expects you to
discover them
you
[Music]